Here's what a scaling matrix looks like. Set all three values here to one and
you get the identity matrix. If you want to uniformly scale something to be
three times as large as before, set SX, SY, and SZ to all be three. If you want
to instead just stretch something up along the Y axis so that it's five times as
tall, set SX and SZ to be one, and SY to be five. There's just one funny thing
that happens with scaling in particular. It can mess up normals. Remember we're
not just transforming points with matrices, we're also transforming shading
normals. If you run normals through a translation matrix, nothing happens to
them. They're vectors so they don't get touched. If you run normals though a
rotation matrix, things are fine. Here's a triangle from a side view, looking
along it's plane, along with it's normal. If you uniformally scale this object
to be larger, look what happens. The object grows larger, as does the normal.
The good news is that the normal doesn't change direction, so all we have to do
is re-normalize it before using it in any lighting equations. If you
non-uniformally scale an object, In other words, stretch or squish it. Things
get weird. Here I stretch the triangle in one direction. The normal vector has
also stretched upwards and is clearly no longer pointing in the right direction.
To solve this problem, we need to inverse and transpose a matrix.